like maybe we'll make this work but now
Oh God
I recently discovered this old YouTube
challenge where people try to bake
cookies blindfolded and without a recipe
so I thought it'd be fun to challenge my
co-workers here at BuzzFeed to do the
same yeah you probably Baker could be
without recipe oh oh no no I can't do
that I think I could definitely a baked
cookie ass blindfolded
I mean Red's my color it matches my
lipstick so we're already off to a great
start
all right everyone let's watch me make
cookies blindfolded with no recipe god
help me okay I'm currently trying to
figure out where all my ingredients are
right chocolate wait I have to check
probably start by putting all the dry
ingredients together and then slowly
adding the wet ingredients I'm gonna
start with the hardest part which i
think is the eggs oh that is not sugar
I don't know what this is this feels
like it's not a half a cup all measuring
has gone out the window since I can't
even see it anyway refers to crack an
egg on the table not the roll it's
supposed to not being shells alright
gotta be careful with vanilla how do I
do this maybe I just my confidence level
is plummeting got two sizes big and
small so maybe you're the salt yep
definitely the salt so again I need one
teaspoon of us I hope that's enough this
is feeling kind of like cookie dough
more chocolate can you have too much
chocolate no no I can already tell the
texture is really off this feels pretty
good no turning back now we're in the
final stages of these delicious cookies
you guys can make at home if you've been
following along so I think these will
cook like cookies but I don't I don't
think they're gonna look like cookies
cool I'm just now looking down it looks
like a baby threw up on a tray you know
what I'm curious to see what's gonna
happen so let's put them in the oven
they look okay
have I seen better cookies absolutely no
you know it's not horrible they didn't
quite rise to the occasion so I thought
they were gonna look a lot better than
they actually do they look really
biscuity I mean I think these are dope
there isn't gooey - all right let's go
through the try you only live once
let's it tastes like bread with
chocolate chips in it on a scale of one
to ten the cookies I made today are um
five I made this cookie sheet ten out of
ten
I didn't know I needed one whole cookie
but sometimes you just get what you
deserve I think like I really went wrong
like I wasn't good taste okay like it
tastes good I think chocolate makes is
good but like the texture is not it all
right I'm really proud of this actually
yeah really crispy on the end that's
great
hell yeah it probably doesn't look good
but I like it
[Music]